(bouncy, cheerful music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Look familiar?
Welcome to the garden of
none other than Claude Monet,
the father of French impressionism.
Worldwide renowned painter who planted
his own garden here in Giverny in 1883,
and replicated it time and
time again on canvases.
And this is Gilbert.
He's an artist in his own right.
He has been responsible for the upkeep
of Monet's garden for over 40 years.
After the second World War,
the garden was left neglected.
So in the 1970s, gardeners
were called to the rescue.
(speaking in foreign language)
Gilbert wasn't the greatest
connoisseur of Monet,
but he got to know him through his garden.
(speaking in foreign language)